Beyonce said,
well,
she was doing her thing.
Three days had gone by.
She forgot she didn't eat.
I never forget when 50 cent was doing
this movie out,
did a little research on 50th 50 said
that when he wasn't doing the movie,
he was doing the soundtrack and they
said,
when do you sleep?
50 sleep.
He says,
sleep.
Sleep is for those people who are broke.
I was asleep
so I got an opportunity to make the
dream become a reality.
The most important thing is this.
To be able at any moment,
to sacrifice what you are for,
what you will be calm,
what would you,
you can make sacrifices when Monday
night football is not on.
You can make a sacrifice,
but when the game come on,
for some reason,
you just attached to it for something to
you.
When your favorite show come on you,
you can be,
you can make sacrifices on Sunday,
but ain't nothing going on.
What were your favorite show comes on
Monday.
Some of you,
you focus into the fall winning and then
you like,
I got an answer.
If I don't answer the phone,
I'm going to die.
I'm saying to you today that there's
some of you
give up your cell phone.
You will be successful.
What's your cell phone is more and nude
in your success.
You know why people do what they do?
The people who go after that stuff.
What makes it worth it?
It's got to be your cash.
You got to love it,
ladies and gentlemen.
You got to love it.
It's gotta be what you are supposed to
do.
You want to say to,
even though they won't invite you to
Carnegie Hall,
you going to say trading bought it.
I listened to your coo.
Sang it to yourself.
I you start talking to my plants when
nobody else would listen to me.
You got to write even if no one
published your book,
right,
because that was given to you to do.
You'll do what it is you're supposed to.
You're supposed to bill something.
You're supposed to create something.
I don't know how to do it.
Whatever's required.
Just go out there.
It's possible you can get what you are.
It's necessary.
If you wanted,
you got to go into action.
You've gotta be willing to experiment.
You've got to be willing to fail and to
succeed.
You got to be willing to form and
develop new relationships.
It's you,
it's on you.
You got to make that happen.
Nobody's going to bring it to you on a
silver platter.
Here's your dream manifested.
No,
it's hard.
Yes.
It's hard.
It's difficult.
Yes.
Right,
and it's worth it.
[inaudible].